let's show you the ingredients bleached
enriched flour ferrous sulfate iron
which is really toxic synthetic vitamins
sugar high fructose corn syrup soy oil
dextrose which is in synthetic sugar
monosodium glutamate more corn starch
artificial flavorings and colorings your
favorite Christmas cream wheat flour
iron again that iron it's gonna sit in
your stomach like a lead balloon soybean
oil sugar gluten salts chemicals
dextrose it's a synthetic sugar
artificial flavoring artificial coloring
the same ingredients this is sugar water
okay incredible sugar water Powerade got
Gatorade but you know what they're going
low sugar because they know people don't
like sugar that's the trend but I'm just
like amazed do people actually buy this
product look how much volume they have
dextrose sugar in dextrose two sugars so
it's all sugar citric acid natural
flavors salt Manas potassium phosphate
this is their electrolyte blend this is
liquid sugar of course you got the juice
over there and then of course we have
our favorite soda over here but
everything is tending to go sugar-free
eventually I'm sure okay so we're gonna
try some low-fat yogurt but of course 15
grams of sugar per cup 15 grams alright
so we got the ice creams here 16 grams
of sugar now when you add that much fat
with that much sugar not a good
combination
you get something called a GE Advance
glycated proteins or end products which
clog up the body handler top seven grams
of sugar still seven grams of sugar too
much mayonnaise swimming oil so I want
to try to find something without the GMO
soybean oil so let's try olive oil male
and it has canola oil and then some
additional soybean oil so they add the
canola oil which is also GMO we don't
want that organic mayonnaise well at
least that'll be non-gmo but they have
the soil again I just don't want any soy
oil this is awesome I found something I
can eat because I know this is good
avocado oil egg yolks water distilled
vinegar it does have organic cane sugar
though that's the problem well it's a
zero so it must be just the like a
little tiny bit so this might be okay
here's a good one too we'll check that
out
Camila Wow
and over here brags I already know this
is good right here you can try that and
then this one right here Stonewall olive
oil and Islamic vinaigrette this is one
that I would recommend everything else
is like corn syrup corn oil or soy oil
man look at look at this look at all
these carbohydrates massive amounts of
sugar I'm being sarcastic this is
something you can eat okay salad
cucumbers okay so now let's look at the
peanut butters right here's a natural
peanut butter the main thing I look at
is do they have peanuts and salt yes
this is good jiffy with honey we don't
we know that's gonna have sweet in it
here's one with peanuts sugar and palm
oil okay Skippy's this is tahini butter
that's fine Richards 100% peanuts okay
good so you just have to read the
ingredients
you know molasses they're putting
molasses in there it's gonna taste good
but that's too much sugar we've got the
organic okay they're really using this
too as a buzzword nowadays rustic white
no artificial colors flavors or
preservatives no high fructose corn
syrup because they know people don't
like that stuff but it still has
enriched wheat it still has it still
turns into sugar really fast so it's
step up but not that high of a step it's
always important to read labels okay
especially if you're trying to get
hummus first of all the label you have
to have a magnifying glass because it's
like so tiny okay but the first
ingredients is canola oil that's GMO
unfortunately
soy oil aren't you found one okay so
this is with sunflower oil no soy oil
this is good okay we found one so always
read the labels for the hidden
ingredients alright guys I'll see you
next video
I've got to feed these trick-or-treaters
[Music]
I'm just gonna go ahead and eat my
normal hey guys so there's a whole bunch
of people that really need this
information so press the share button
and let's get it way out there